kommen wir nach vietnam seit mehreren
wochen sprechen wir mit christine ehlers
sie ist touristin und sitzt seit dem 9
märz in vietnam unter quarantäne
mittlerweile hat sie im test bekommen
ist negativ und wir möchten mal
nachfragen wie es hier geht und wann sie
denn glaubt dass sie endlich nach
deutschland nach hause kehren kann hallo
frau ehlers können abend aus vietnam
wie geht es ihnen wie ist die situation
bei ihnen vor ort mir geht es den
umständen entsprechend so weit gut
wir sind jetzt knapp 30 touristen aus
deutschland receiver franzosen und
briten die hier seit dem 14
märz in quarantäne so zu sagen das sitze
ich bin am 9 märz angereist
ja wir warten wir warten auf unser
zweites das ergebnis noch einmal ein
zweiter test absolvieren weil bei den
briten einmal leider positiv getestet
wurde also begann das ganze spiel noch
mal von vorne
wir machen das beste aus der situation
wir bleiben ruhig
man merkt wie sich die behörden mehr und
mehr wirklich bemühen es wurden uns
gestern kleine geschenke geliefert in
form von kaffee also klar in
schokotörtchen und was brauchen sagt
also es werde ich wirklich sehr bemüht
auch von außen dass man dass es einem
hier soweit gut geht
nichtsdestotrotz haben wir heute noch
mal aufbauen es gibt immer noch kein
ergebnis
wir sind noch nicht da und es ist immer
ein bisschen bangen dabei wie die
nächsten ergebnisse ausfallen
gibt es denn schon irgendwie eine
tendenz wann eine rückkehr nach
deutschland möglich ist gibt es
irgendwie ein datum an dem sie mal einen
flieger besteigen können nach hause
kehren können wir haben tatsächlich null
information es in die gerüchte rum das
werden jeder negativ getestet wir dass
man am 24 märz herauskommt es kann dann
noch zwei tage dauern so so auch die
gerüchte wir haben alles nur aus
gerüchten erfahren weil es keiner kann
ansprechpartner gibt man muss dann
eventuell noch zwei bis drei tage warten
damit man ein gesundheitszertifikat
bekommt das benötigt man zur ausreise am
flughafen und dann ist natürlich auch
die große frage wie man zurück kommen
wir haben heute ein schreiben des
deutschen konsulats erhalten dass fast
alle airlines ihren betrieb einstellen
und das ist dann auch die große frage
wir haben es jetzt mal umgeschaut welche
airlines überhaupt fliegen aber es gibt
eigentlich kaum noch möglichkeiten und
sobald wir wissen wann wir hier
rauskommen müssen wir uns sehr intensiv
ja viele vielen deutschen fällt jetzt
schon das dach auf den kopf wenn sie die
ganze zeit zu hause sitzen müssen und
wissen nicht mehr wie sie sich
beschäftigen sollen wie ist das für sie
in vietnam in einem eingesperrt in einem
hotel
ja wer will ihm tatsächlich in den tag
hinein
es geht um 38 immer los mit fieber
messen dass täglicher fieber messen
da muss man sich im gemeinschaftsraum
und versammeln
da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen wird es
immer ein bisschen ruhiger jeder hat
immer sorge und immer muss abliefern
man muss man selbst banker haben sonst
wird man hier gleich raus geholt
das hat in den letzten tagen geklappt
und wenn das vorbei ist also ich hatte
immer glück war ich hatte kein zebra
meine freunde aus deutschland auch nicht
dann ja setzt man sich draußen hin wir
setzen uns wir halten uns viel draußen
auf man man ist durch dirk man trinkt
ein thema bringt ein café man schaut
immer wieder aufs tor auf irgendetwas
passiert wir haben ja auch gar keine
informationen
das heißt man wartet einfach und sie
zwischen draußen und schwarz ich bin
einfach an und natürlich halte ich sehr
sehr viel kontakt in die heimat ich bin
sehr viel am handy glücklicherweise gibt
es derweil bei und man unterhält sich
auch den miteinander und
ich persönlich militär auch viel macht
übung und yoga und so schlägt man sich
eigentlich von tag zu tag durch den park
wie viele menschen sind denn in dem
hotel und wie kann man denn dort
überhaupt abstand auch zueinander halten
wir sind knapp 30 personen also zwei
deutsche und dann so hälfte halb da kann
man eigentlich sagen briten und
franzosen
es ist ein verlassenes hotel das uns war
die ganze verfügung steht wir bewohnen
eine etage die vierte etage hier
das ist so praktisch wie auf
klassenfahrt dass man so zimmer an
zimmer wohnt also abstands mäßig ist das
jetzt hier gar nicht so gegeben und man
trifft sich natürlich im
gemeinschaftsraum ist ja relativ klein
wo man gemeinsam ist man geht gemeinsam
zur schleuse um essen abzuholen ob um
neue lieferung abzuholen und zu werden
auch wir zum beispiel toilettenpapier
wenn es alle ist hier eingebracht oder
andere dinge was wird uns gebracht
also abstand ist hier um ehrlich zu sein
gar nicht so sehr zu denken
kriegen sie denn irgend etwas mit was
außerhalb dieses hotels passiert wie
vietnam mit dem virus um geht gibt es in
einen zaun über dem man wenigstens
darüber sehen kann oder müssen wir uns
das komplett abgeriegelt vorstellen
ich bin als in der zweiten unterkunft in
der ersten unterkunft war es tatsächlich
alles abgeriegelt und habt ihr nicht so
viel weitsicht
jetzt wo wir in einem film stecken hotel
das heißt wir haben ein aussicht aus dem
zimmer fenster also vom beziehungsweise
auch vom balkon man backen wir weiter
sehen und es ist so skurril war wirklich
das tägliche leben sehen ich habe vorhin
eine montag gesehen wie sie mit ihren
beiden kindern drachen hat steigen
lassen in der nähe ist eine karaoke-bar
wir hören
24 stunden rund um die uhr aus unserem
zimmer karaoke musik das ist so skurril
ansonsten von unten sehen wir also vom
haupteingang sehen wir tatsächlich leute
die sie gerade zeigen
da sehen wir eben diesen tisch und
dahinter ist dann hinter dem ohr ist
eine straße also so viel sehen wir hier
nicht wir haben natürlich bei
wlan-zugang das heißt wir lesen die
nachrichten wir lesen und merken auch
selber weh streng vietnam mit dem virus
umgeht
aktuell so ist mir bekannt gibt es hier
5 und 8
die fälle im ganzen land und in der
region in der ich mich befinde gibt es
drei bekannte fälle
und sobald irgendwo jemand positiv
getestet wird
denken sie wirklich sehr sehr sehr viele
menschen fahren und es wurde auch gesagt
dass auch hier in der stadt in der ich
mich befinde die touristen zum teil
einfach aufgegriffen werden und getestet
werden zum tagen quarantäne gesteckt
werden ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt aber
ich weiß wenn ihr merken es dass vietnam
sehr sehr konsequent rock it
wie behält man bei so einer in so einer
situation die halbwegs gute laune sie
können er dennoch recht fröhlich von
diesen vorkommnissen berichten
wie schaffen sie es außer mit meditation
so durch den tag zu kommen gibt es
freunde die man findet helfen vielleicht
die telefonate mit den lieben zu hause
was macht man in den minuten der
verzweiflung dort ich bin tatsächlich
mit einer sehr guten freundin hier das
heißt wenn ich hier alleine gewesen wäre
weil das schon mal was ganz anderes wir
tauschen uns viel aus ansonsten ja man
spricht hier miteinander und ich denke
der kontakt nach hause oder vom meer ist
sehr sehr wichtig ich habe ein sehr
großes netzwerk auch durch durch mein
arbeitgeber durch meine yoga meditation
gruppe die in 156 ländern vertreten ist
ich bekomme so viele nachrichten jeden
tag aus indien aus den usa aus
verschiedenen europäischen ländern und
mit vielen aufmunternden worten und dass
er dann wirklich hier bei laune und mehr
kann man auch nicht machen wenn ich
jetzt am eingang steht und bei nacht
bringt mich das auch nicht weiter man
muss hier wirklich akzeptieren was sache
ist dass man keine infos bekommt und das
glaube ich hat jetzt jeder aus der
gruppe ich hier auch gemacht und ich tue
es eben so eine situation hilft
wahrscheinlich auch wirklich nur eine
pragmatische sicht auf die dinge letzte
frage sollte der spuk vorüber sein sie
sind endlich wieder zurück in
deutschland käme für sie eine weite
fernreise in den nächsten jahren
überhaupt noch mal infrage
auf jeden fall ist man das konnte keiner
erwarten ich bin die ganze situation
weil in meinem flugzeug von paris nach
hanoi zwei leute positiv getestet worden
sind wir haben es auch in den
nachrichten gesehen das wirklich auch
gerade aus großbritannien diejenigen
dass italien als reisen zum teil einige
fälle hier ins land bringen da kann
keiner was für und mittlerweile bemüht
sich die regierung sehr dass es uns gut
geht und es ist nicht so dass ich jetzt
ein großes drama habe und überhaupt
nicht mehr verreisen möchte denke das
ist natürlich wird man das wenn man zu
hause ist erstmal noch mal
taktieren müssen verarbeiten müssen aber
einer weiteren fernreise sollte
eigentlich nichts im wege stehen
frau ehlers wir wünschen ihnen dass es
für sie bald nach hause geht und bleiben
sie weiterhin so tapfer in dieser
situation vielen dank für das gespräch